my overall assessment of sauna based on
the literature is the mechanisms are
fascinating and i like physiology
i think it is probably it probably has
modest positive health benefits related
to cardio metabolic health and
cardiovascular health i certainly don't
view it
as a replacement for exercise or
physical activity i think it's almost
like hey
it's better than nothing but not as good
as you know more traditional forms of
exercise to benefit cardiometabolic
outcomes and cardiovascular outcomes uh
i think if you're someone with a
low cardio respiratory fitness level
who's at high cardio metabolic health
risk at baseline you might have to some
extent an additive effect of doing a
little bit more exercise and a little
bit of sauna in the mix
but as you start to get to a higher
fitness level i think it's more likely
that those health health-related
benefits of sauna become
increasingly modest and potentially at
some point even a little bit redundant
in the context of someone who is at a
really high fitness level uh so in in
summary i think what you would expect
with sauna is nutri neutral to modestly
positive health outcomes um but but it's
certainly not a replacement i mean one
of the things that i mentioned is a
critical distinction is you know you do
get some of these uh indicators that's
like oh sauna does this exercise also
does that but the fact that you have an
increase in cardiac output without an
increase in stroke volume the increase
in stroke volume is a really major
driver of a lot of the positive
cardiovascular adaptations that we make
to aerobic type exercise so yeah it's
not like a full exercise replacement but
like i said probably better than nothing
and one of the things i find most
fascinating about it uh as i do it
myself
i was reading a great review paper about
um
exercise and appetite and they were
suggesting in that review paper that the
increase in body heat that we
experienced during exercise might play a
causative role in suppressing appetite
after exercise acutely
and it was it was hypothetical it was
speculative it was not something that i
would take to the bank but i have
noticed that when i do sauna
uh it does seem to transiently blunt my
appetite to some extent which i think is
really fascinating it's something i've
noticed with sauna but i don't
particularly notice with exercise to be
honest uh but anyway you know there's
there's a lot of interesting stuff
related to sauna and i'm hoping that
we'll get more randomized control trials
to kind of dig into some of these
mechanisms but i will say
an important thing to keep in mind is
that saunas are hot
and heat stress is a serious
physiological stressor so if you have
any kind of uh
you know noteworthy or relevant uh
medical condition you'll want to make
sure that you consult with a prof a
medical professional to make sure that
it is safe for you to engage in
extended periods of time in this level
of heat stress because it can be quite
serious you know i'm curious the the
body heat and
appetite thing
i i would want to read that paper what
occurs to me because like i also don't
want to eat after
after i get really hot
but it's just because i'm sweaty and i
don't want to eat when i'm sweaty
because i feel like
i just feel slimy and i feel like i'm
just going to get sweat and muck all
over everything that i'm eating and so
like
i i don't know
i one i wonder if you could
manipulate shut down sweat
but uh still make people hot if you
would see if you would see the same
impact well good luck running that study
i'm sure the irb would love that we're
gonna oh yeah introduce heat stress and
then remove the human mechanism to
actually dissipate heat yeah just just
figure out how quickly the subjects in
that study can learn how to pant exactly
yeah uh yeah i'll put that that review
in the show notes that was talking more
about um
you know exercise and heat and appetite
that wasn't the main focus of the paper
it was one subsection
but yeah i'll put that in the show notes
and i'll send it to you after the show
and you can take a look at it maybe
we'll revisit on the show later like i
said that that to me is something i was
like oh that's an interesting thing i do
the sauna because i like it but i have
noticed that i do have some some notable
appetite suppression for a couple hours
afterward um now
i'm not in a calorie deficit um i'm just
at maintenance level so
uh it's very possible that once you get
into a deficit it's just like whatever
you're still hungry like yeah uh it is
interesting like if there's one thing
you learn from bodybuilding it's that a
severe calorie deficit combined with low
body fat can cut through damn near
anything like yeah well
so after like yeah after a hard workout
in the heat after i go play basketball
whatever
i do want to consume calories like just
some sort of like calorific beverage
yeah but i don't want to put food in my
mouth yeah uh
so yeah i i feel like i feel like i am
experienced in experiencing
physiological hunger but i just feel
gross if i eat while i'm very sweaty
yeah well yeah we'll uh maybe revisit
that but at the bare minimum i'll put
that link in the show notes and people
can uh engage in the controversy and
form their own opinion so that's good
but yeah so sauna like i said neutral to
modestly positive health benefits i
think it's
a lovely cultural practice i think it's
very fun and cool there seems to be a
social element in certain countries that
that is you know really cool like i kind
of wish we had it here uh and i love
doing sauna because i think it feels
great and like i said yeah maybe you get
some minor health benefits from it maybe
not but as long as there's no
contraindication as long as you don't
have a relevant medical issue that would
prevent you from using sauna you know i
certainly see no reason to
restrict yourself from doing something
that can be very enjoyable very relaxing